je vais vous raconter une histoire
l'histoire des entreprises françaises
dans la reconstruction des pays post
crise quand j'étais à sarajevo
j'ai constaté assez rapidement que après
la phase critique qui étaient en général
résorbé par l'action militaire et avec
l'aide des ong
on rentrait dans la phase de
reconstruction
c'est à dire la reconstruction des
fondamentaux de la vie d'un pays pour
que ce pays puisse de nouveau revivre
normalement et se développer les
fondamentaux vous pouvez imaginer
c'est long c'est l'électricité c'est le
bâtiment c e sont les routes les ponts
c'est la santé
c'est l'éducation ces mêmes l'état civil
l'état de droit la justice
enfin tout ce qui fait un pays est un
pays qui se tient cette reconstruction
bénéficie de nombreux financements par
centaines de milliards de dollars les
financements qui viennent soit des
étangs soit d'organisations
internationales comme l'onu ou l'europe
et à ma grande surprise lorsque cette
phase de reconstruction est entamée je
vois des entreprises italiennes
je vois des entreprises allemandes je
vois des entreprises américaines
anglaises et pas de français alors que
la france est présente depuis plus de
trois ou quatre ans ce qui était le cas
de sarajevo qu'on avait mis cinq ou six
mille hommes sur le terrain et personne
pour reconstruire
pour imager mon propos je vais vous
donner un exemple que j'ai appelé
les vitres de sarajevo vous imaginez
bien que après quatre ans de conflit
notamment aux zones urbaines et bien il
y avait plus de vitres aux fenêtres de
toutes les fenêtres de la ville de
sarajevo
or dans ce pays vous le savez bien
l'hiver la température descend
facilement à moins 20 degrés quant à
l'été elle monte jusqu'à 30 35 et donc
les populations souffrent notamment
parce que à la place des vitres ont
leurs amis
le plastique unhcr et qu' il faudrait
bien revenir à des choses normales
l'europe en 96
après les accords de dayton quand la
stabilité est intervenue l'europe a
décidé de financer cette mise en place
des vitres
les français présents notamment au
travers de l'action civilo-militaires se
tourner vers saint gobain et 10 à saint
gobain il ya des vitres à remettre à
sarajevo
les allemands eux se tournent vers l'or
saint gobain mais embauches tout les
vitriers de la ville qui étaient au
chômage en attente d'occupation pour
remettre en place les carreaux des
fenêtres de leur résidence et donc les
allemands récupèrent le marché et les
français de crier au drame
parce que c'était pas eux qui alors
qu'ils étaient là depuis cinq ans avenue
le marché que faisait l'état
que faisait la france que faisait tout
pour éviter ce genre de situation
deuxième exemple quelques années plus
tard les forces françaises la france
intervient au mali
on envoie cinq mille hommes on a un
certain nombre de morts est la première
action de reconstruction est menée par
les américains qui repeignent le palais
présidentiel à bamako et là mon sang ne
fait qu'un tour
je dis c'est pas possible qu'on en soit
toujours là je participe à un colloque
sur ce sujet à lyon en présence du medef
de la cgpme des fédérations du bâtiment
de militaires bien sûr à et j'entends et
le quai d'orsay
et j'entends un certain nombre de
personnes dire oui il serait souhaitable
il faudrait que l'état ce serait bien
il n'ya pas y'a qu'à faut qu'on
et quand tu viens mon tour de parole je
le redis écouter avec tout le respect
que je vous dois
ça fait 20 ans que j'entends le même
discours et ça fait 20 ans qu'il ne se
passe rien peut-être qu'il y à d'autres
solutions
et peut-être que il serait souhaitable
que l'on se prennent peut-être par la
main pour essayer de résoudre ce
problème sans attendre que l'état
ce fameux état fasse quelque chose pour
un militaire tenir des discours de ce
type
sacré quand même quelques soucis parce
qu'un militaire c'est quand même les
temps
et un militaire qui se permet de dire
que l'état ne fait ne fait rien c'est
quand même un peut-être un mauvais
militaire mais la chance me sourit parce
que dans le cabinet d'avocats dans
lequel j'exerce mes talents je tombe sur
deux avocats pénalistes du social est un
jeune ingénieur informaticien mais
spécialiste des plateformes numériques
et des réseaux sociaux et dans ce
cabinet alors que bien souvent pour
régler nos problèmes et notamment ceux
qui étaient les miens c'est à dire
l'anticipation du risque juridique pour
les chefs d'entreprise nous étions
aperçus qu'on avait besoin d'un certain
nombre de sachants pour venir nous aider
dans notre démarche et surtout on s'est
aperçu au gré de nos rencontres que en
france c'était toujours les mêmes qui
parlait à la télévision ces fameuses
experts qui souvent sont experts parce
qu'ils se sont désignés comme expert et
vous tiennent le crachoir pendant des
soirées entières à la télévision pour
dire souvent tout et n'importe quoi dans
le domaine qui m'est cher c'est-à-dire
les domaines de sécurité défense je peux
vous dire que temps en temps en
regardant la télévision je suis accroché
à mon siège et mon épouse me donne
quelques calmant un pour que je puisse
dormir tranquillement dans la nuit et
donc au gré comme je disais de nos
rencontres
on s'était rendu compte que c'est ce qu'
il y avait un grand nombre de personnes
dans la société civile qui s'achève qui
savait
qu'ils étaient des sachants mais qu'ils
n'avaient pas le moyen de s'exprimer et
donc on a décidé de créer une plateforme
numérique et de créer sept groupements
de sachant qu'on a appelée cercle k2 un
cercle comme un cercle
k2 comme la montagne c'est à dire
l'objectif qu'on atteint difficilement
voire jamais mais on a quand même un
objectif et ce cercle k2 devait
regrouper une cinquantaine de personnes
essentiellement des universitaires des
juristes des personnes de la sécurité
défense
les chefs d'entreprise c'est-à-dire tout
ce qui faisait la vie économique du pays
et au bout de quatre ans d'existence
cinq ans même maintenant eh bien nous
sommes mille
nous avons non pas recruter 1000
personnes nous avons simplement fait
venir mille personnes qui ont trouvé à
la fois de la lumière une chaleur
sympathique d'anim d'amitié et surtout
la capacité de s'exprimer par des vidéos
par des rencontres et surtout par le
fait qu' il pouvait se regrouper et
temporairement dans le cadre je dirais
de réflexion pour traiter de sujets des
sujets pour le rencontrer dira
transverse pour lesquelles il fallait et
on pouvait apporter une solution
opérationnelle
et donc j'ai profité de cette occasion
pour leur dire écoutez les enfants à les
y réfléchissons sur le problème de la
reconstruction post crise puisque de
toute façon ça n'aboutit fort et là on a
réuni un grand nombre de personnes ont
été plus de 60 à une certaine et un
certain moment et on l'a fait à lyon
parce que là les personnes étaient
plutôt disponible sur lyon puisque le
cercle k2 a une dimension nationale et
internationale et à lyon avec l'aide du
medef
ces pme avec la fédération du bâtiment
et autres nous avons travaillé pendant
deux ans et pendant ces deux années nous
avons réfléchi à comment il fallait
s'organiser pour pouvoir répondre aux
besoins des pays qui était en
reconstruction et au travers des
financements que 2 est elle qui était
disponible et qui était donné par les
organismes que j'ai cités tout à l'heure
et au bout de ces deux ans nous avons
conclu qu'il fallait créer une structure
privée que l'on a appelé hors actions
france auvergne
ronald actions france structure privée
qui est dédié et qui est destiné à faire
du privé public c'est à dire que on
n'attend pas du public
on attend simplement que le public nous
apporte nous importe je dirais quelques
quelques accompagnements et sa structure
elle existe maintenant depuis deux ans
elle a regroupé une dizaine
d'entreprises du bâtiment des travaux
publics de l'énergie du photovoltaïque
et de la boulangerie
parce que en afrique comme chacun sait
on mange deux baguettes par jour
et donc il n'est pas inintéressant de
mettre des fours des fours soient
industrielles soient artisanaux et donc
cette structure qui s'est organisée je
dirais sur deux étages un étage qui est
plutôt un étage d'intelligence
économique un étage d'un flux ans un
étage d'anticipation un étage de
planification un étage d'études et
d'ingénierie
c'est à dire la partie amont et puis
ensuite dans des tâches d'exécution par
des entreprises qui ont la volonté de
pouvoir se projeter
sur le terrain on n'est pas dans
l'export on est dans la projection
économique et d'aller donc sur le
terrain pour faire et pour faire avec
qui est bien pour faire avec les locaux
c'est-à-dire d'accompagner les
entreprises locales qui seules n'ont pas
la capacité notamment dans les pays qui
ont subi la crise qu'ils n'ont pas la
capacité de faire seul mais qui avec
nous ont la capacité de réaliser les
projets qui répondent aux besoins de la
population locale
alors pour conclure on a évoqué de
l'impossible au possible l'impossible
n'existe pas il n'y a pas de fatalité il
faut simplement avoir une volonté avoir
un objectif s'y tenir et rassembler
autour de soi le maximum de personne
parce que chacun a la réponse à une
partie de la réponse à la question posée
est donc on est dans l'intelligence
collective
encore faut-il que ces personnes
veuillent bien travailler avec vous
réfléchir avec vous mais rassurez vous
il ya pas de doute ils existent et ils
le font mais aussi il faut faire preuve
d'une certaine générosité il faut pas
chercher tout de suite un profit à
profit que ce soit de gloire
ou un profit financier car très
rapidement on va à l'échec
en fait le retour sur investissement et
interviendra quand on aura atteint le
possible enfin je vous remercie